remember the last time you fold with the
tip up yeah there wasn't a fish on the
end of it no there wasn't you remember
what was on the end of it of course you
remember of course I remember what was
on the end of it when I finally realized
what it was I tried everything to get
you out of the house to give you that
engagement ring that that ring was
burning a hole in my pocket for like
weeks
finally I baited you an ice-fishing you
know how I got you to go ice fishing
because I'm a sucker for ice fishing
I've never seen anyone get more excited
about anything than you do about
catching those freaking dollies out of
the hole in Iliamna I put the ring at
the bottom of the lake on my tip up and
then right when I was going to tell you
to go and check the tip up you saw that
frickin Artic hair and you took off on
the Honda chasing the Artic hair and I
was like man I almost chickened out
right then and then I was like actually
this is why I'm asking this girl to
marry me because she's the type of girl
the chases part of her hotness 45 miles
an hour
you pull the ring up you look at it you
don't identify it as a ring weight and
you just I don't know what your damn
riggings were with these tip ups I had
no idea what was going on you take my
ring and throw it onto the ice you threw
the ring home after your tip up I didn't
realize there was a ring attached to the
end of the one then I had a small heart
attack and almost chickened out on the
whole thing again so I went I rigged it
all up again I waited til you weren't
looking set off the flag I ran away went
back to my hole and I'm like aw Martha
go check it go check it and then what
you do what did you do that
oh just get X is no damn fish in that
hole and I wasn't checking your stupid
tip up no I begged you begged you and
you went over there and then well super
annoyed not fair that's like 2 miles
long all right so what did you do the
second time I did the same thing I did
the first time I threw it out on the ice
so there's no damn fish down in your
hole and I had another heart attack
went and rigged the whole thing up a
third time set the flag over and made
her
with me over to check it no you made you
were like there's got to be a fish down
here let's watch and then you pulled it
up right in front of me and you're like
there's no fish and then I shined the
light right on the ring and it sparkled
and then you went like this oh-oh-oh I
think you had a pretty good catch in the
end of the deal
you